well it has been a very tough first four
weeks for endlessly lying Republican
Congressman George Anthony Katara
devolder Santos uh not only has he been
caught in numerous additional lies since
taking office he has already been
accused of sexual harassment or sexual
harassment if some some of our
1990s politics followers May uh may
remember it being pronounced
um let's take a look at what the
allegations are the New York Times
reports George Santos accused of sexual
harassment and Capitol Hill office the
complaint was made by a man seeking work
as a house aide whose bid for a job was
rejected because he faced criminal
wiretapping charges in Ohio
uh the man Derrick Myers briefly worked
for Santos's office before the offer was
rescinded earlier this week according to
the letter Meyer said in the letter he
was alone with Santos on in his office
on January 25 when the congressman asked
him whether he had a profile on Grindr a
popular gay dating app then he said Mr
Santos invited him to karaoke and
touched his groin assuring him that his
husband was out of town Mr Meyer's
account could not be corroborated but a
spokeswoman for representative Susan
Wilde acknowledged that this that his
letter had been received by her office
Meyer said in an interview he did file a
report with the Capitol Police speaking
to an officer over the phone
on Twitter he said he was making his
complaint public for the sake of
transparency
they are serious offenses and evidence
and facts will speak for themselves if
the committee takes up the matter
um
so
one of the things that I think is
important here
is we don't want in our criticisms of
George Santos to fall into homophobic
tropes and so as an example George
Santos lied about many things he lied
about uh his ethnicity
he lied about his work history he lied
about his educational history he lied
about his
um history in athletics he lied about
his medical history he appears to have
lied about the death of his mother
claiming that she died at at least twice
and on and on and on and also we have
this thing where even though he says he
was open openly gay he was married to a
woman and these different things I've
stayed away from the married to a woman
thing because I'm aware that in society
because of stigma and shame that is
launched at LGBT folks in many instances
there is a long history of gay men who
also were married at some point to women
and so I've kind of stayed away from
that because there's so much other stuff
that we can criticize him for even if I
mean like you know there's this conflict
where he said he was he was openly gay
but I we don't even really need to get
into that and I don't want to get in
anywhere near any of these homophobic
tropes on the sexual harassment thing
there are Republicans who are very
quickly saying this is the problem with
gay men
that this is has nothing to do with him
being gay he is gay so the guy he
allegedly sexually harassed happens to
be a man but we have seen most elements
of sexual harassment by members of the
House and Senate that they are
heterosexual and so I want to be careful
in our coverage of this to stay away
from anything approximating that
homophobic Trope we've talked about the
homo homophobic Trope about gay men as
pedophiles and the homophobic Trope
about gay men as sexual harassers and we
want to be clear in our coverage that
that is not our story now that all being
said
I do think it's important to remember
for example when former Democratic
senator Al Franken resigned after just
the accusation of sexual misconduct
which turned out to be a tasteless joke
that took place years before Franken was
even in elected office he took a
tasteless tasteless picture where he
pretended he was going to touch a
sleeping woman and in their effort I
guess to show how not like Republicans
they are even many Democrats demanded
Franken resign and he did and uh we want
to be conscious of the differences in a
lot of these different circumstances
they are not all the same Santos is very
quickly becoming the prototypical
Republican uh that is for sure and
there's also the element of how stupid
is this guy and what I mean by that is
got caught lying about everything under
multiple investigations and on January
5th as the audacity to allegedly do
something like this in his own office
and yes Democrats would have removed the
sky a long time ago Democrats aren't
perfect I don't care about the
Democratic party in any particular way
but on this issue there is no chance in
hell that if Santos were a Democrat and
got caught doing the things he's he's
got caught doing uh there's no chance he
is still in office and that is
abundantly clear
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below